So let's have a look at some of the
implications of using multiple filters. This one is a concern.
Deployed apps must have composite indexes for all filter combinations.
If you try to run a query for which the
composite index does not exist, you will get an
error. Your users will see the error on the deployed
app, so be very careful about that. Do the multiple
filters per query increase data store writes? Definitely they do,
so for the conference for every time you write an
index entry, you have multiple writes every time you save
the conference. And again, the more index entries you have
the more space they take up in the data store. So
let's take a look at what the index configuration file
might look like. We have a lot of different index
entries in here. I'm not going to read through them all
but you can see that, know we have one for conference,
filter by city, sorting by name, conference, filtering
by top pick, sorting by name, and so on
and so on. So, for every possible combination that
you going to allow the user to filter on, you
need to add that combination to your index
configuration file. And here we're looking at the indexes
in the data store viewer and the admin console.
I just uploaded my app with all the indexes.
And you see they're busy preparing. But you see how
many of them there are. You need to be aware of
the need for indexes. Every query that your users are going
to make has to have an index. And if it requires
a composite index, you're going to need to make sure that
the composite index exists on your application. And although this combination
of filters uses many indexes, the results of the queries are
fast because every search is pre-indexed so the query performance scales
with the size of the result set, not the input
data set. It's one of the great things about App Engine.